innues de parler à dieu pas sanitaire
avec et rémy rebeyrotte député de la
république en marge de saône-et-loire et
michel larive député de la france
insoumise de la 2e circonscription de
l'ariège
bonsoir à vous dis merci d'être avec
nous sur rt france ce soir je me tourne
d'abord vers vous rémy rebeyrotte le
projet de loi sur le pass and i ter la
vaccination obligatoire des soignants et
débattue en ce moment même à l'assemblée
nationale et débats plutôt houleux comme
on pouvait s y attendre ce projet
louette est il réellement la seule
solution pour lutter contre cette
quatrième vague
oui je crois qu'effectivement d'autres
solutions sofa confiné et rapidement et
intégralement les flamands n'est pas un
choix non je voulais dire mon dieu il ya
trois mois j'étais très défavorable à la
généralisation du personnel pour une
simple et bonne raison c'est qu'il n'y
avait pas d'alternative pour nos
concitoyens qui ne pouvaient pas à
l'époque se faire vacciner de manière
massive
on était dans le début de la vaccination
les rendez-vous et est souvent compliqué
pour être tri et donc on était dans une
situation très différente de siècle
aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui nous avons le variant delta
avec les problèmes imminents extrêmement
parce qu'il pose
mais nous avons heureusement le vaccin
la capacité vaccinale et la capacité
matelot de vacciner vite puisqu'elle
nous avions même les centres de
vaccination qui était en chute de
fréquentation
quand les choses ont semblé pour nous
français allait mieux
en réalité nous avons pour d'une part y
en ait il faut reprendre massivement la
voie de la vaccination
mais cette voie aujourd'hui elle est
ouverte très très clairement
alors le pass sanitaire ne pas se
traduire par la vaccination obligatoire
parce qu'il ya toujours possibilité des
tests pcr mais enfin quand même l'idéal
soyons clairs c'est la vaccination et
c'est d'aller le plus rapidement
possible accomplir ce ce droit est
finalement aussi ceux de voir ce devoir
pour les ou michel larive vous
interpelle sur sur sa la france
insoumise a été l'un des premiers partis
à vouloir saisir le conseil
constitutionnel pour dénoncer
cette loi finalement le premier ministre
a annoncé qu' le saisir à lui même après
l adoption du parlement qu'est ce que ça
vous évoque une une prise de conscience
finalement un concernant une atteinte
aux libertés individuelles selon vous
oui oui monsieur vous venez de le dire
même la cnil l'a dit et le premier
ministre à juste raison a dit qu'il
saisirait le conseil constitutionnel et
vous avez raison avec le groupe ps gdr
la france a soumises va saisir le
conseil constitutionnel parce qu'elle
fectivement il y à de grave atteinte à
nos libertés individuelles dans ce texte
de loi
comprenez bien contre comprenez bien que
nous ne sommes pas contre la vaccination
je suis moi même vacciné et que
quasiment tout l'ensemble du groupe
parlementaire la france assouplisse de
vacciner ou en cours de vaccination non
ce qui se passe ici c'est que vous avez
par exemple de déclarations très fortes
de stigmatisation qui sont celles de
notre président de la république qui dit
partout seront la même démarche
reconnaître le civisme et faire porter
la restriction sur les nouveaux vacciner
plutôt que sur tous ça c'est
discriminatoire est derrière nous avons
elisabeth bornes qui nous dit on a
introduit une procédure de suspension du
contrat de travail sans rémunération
pour les salariés sont pas sanitaire
valide
là nous avons une rupture de notre
contrat social républicain
alors c'est à ce titre là que nous
imposons aux patients ni terre et mon
collègue très justement à rappeler qu'il
y à trois mois la république en marche
et le président en premier était
défavorable à l'install l'instauration
d'un pass sanitaire parce que lui-même
trouvé que c'était une atteinte aux
libertés individuelles
alors voilà voilà pourquoi nous opposons
à ce texte comment comment le
gouvernement compte-t-il faire et
surtout quelles implications ceci va
avoir j'arrive d'avignon avignon il ya
des termes qui vont fermer là alors
qu'elle je leur ai dit la loi n'est pas
passée attendait qu'elle passe parce
qu'elle peut ne pas passer cette loi est
donc là ils nous disent nous n'aurons
pas le personnel
le syndeac notamment nous dit un
syndicat culturel qui nous dit nous
n'aurons pas le personnel pour pouvoir
faire les vérifications qui va faire les
vérifications de vérification en ariège
et une restauratrice qui me dit mais
comment je vais faire
moi je vais imposer la vaccination à mes
salariés et comment je vais faire quand
les gens vont s'asseoir je vais leur
demander s'ils ont un pass et leurs
pièces d'identité c'est pas mon boulot
je suis restauratrice je suis pas
policier et j'ai rencontré des gendarmes
qui étaient tout aussi dubitatif
il m'a dit écoutez on a vu que pour nos
amis pompiers
c'est est obligatoire et pas pour nous
on comprends pas parce qu'on côtoie
autant de public que nos amis pompiers
et donc voilà donc c'est une loi qui a
été décidée unilatéralement par le
président de la république qui n'est pas
préparée et qui à chaque fois va avoir
un impact sur les gens sur leur travail
considérable parce que ne vous inquiétez
pas il n'y aura pas de sanitaires pour
entrer dans le métro pour aller
travailler pour faire tourner la machine
économique pour que les les premiers de
cordée sont au boulot là il n'y a pas de
passes tony terre c'est après est donc
là nous avons nous un énorme problème et
monsieur cédric au ministre la dans
l'hémicycle vient de dire
qu'effectivement cette loi l'empêchera
peut-être pas des recoupements ou
d'autres coups de feu à venir alors vous
voyez
par contre ce qui se passe c'est que ça
crée un précédent saclay de césure
démocratique et qui à mon humble avis
n'est pas dans le principe de ce mois je
pense de notre république est une
république sociale et donner la parole
concernant justement ce projet de loi
vous qu'on vous comprenez ces
inquiétudes des français vous comprenez
qu'ils ne puissent pas avoir de schéma
vaccinal complet avant avant la rentrée
et que c'est finalement comme comme le
dit michel larive 7 ce projet de loi
était un peu dans l'urgence et ça met un
peu la pression au français
surtout qu'une grande majorité français
sont favorables à la vaccination et que
monsieur arrive pas contre la
vaccination oui je connais sont pour la
vaccination
une grande d'accéder une grande majorité
de français vaccinés souhaitent ou
maximum éviter de nouveaux des
reconfigurations une économie
de nouveau je désire dysfonctionnements
au sein de notre économie plus vite
possible retrouver une vie je
qualifierais de agréable et normal et
donc une grande majorité françaises
soyons clairs sont aujourd'hui tout à
fait favorables au projet de loi est
tout à fait favorable à la vaccination
il reste certain nombre de français et
c'est tout à fait légitime tout le monde
s'exprime on peut aller effectivement
venir manifester je m'étais de
l'assemblée nationale avec le soutien de
la france a soumise tout ça est
parfaitement j'allais dire organiser et
c'est tout à fait légal de notre pays qu
il ya aucun problème mais il faudrait
pas prendre
j'allais dire comment dire il faudrait
pas prendre les dessine des oppositions
et des minorités pour le désir de la
magnum ça vous vous laissez pas la
république c'est pas la république
c'est peut-être monsieur arrive mais
c'est pas la nôtre à signaler c'est que
la plupart des manifestants que l'on
peut voir dans la rue ne sont pas contre
la vaccination mais contre le pass
sanitaire l' usage quotidien et c'est
cette mesure qui est importante
merci merci merci monsieur alors écoutez
chers collègues vous venez de dire que
les français étaient en majorité pour le
vaccin
nous ne sommes pas contre le vaccin nous
sommes contre la manière autoritaire de
procédés de le gouvernement procède et
en plus je vous le redis ou peut-être ne
veut pas entendu cedrico la vie ça
n'évitera pas à re confinement si jamais
il fallait faire donc ne dit pas que ça
évite un confinement
ensuite s'il vous plaît soyez courtois
j'étais courteau nous ne sommes pas à
l'origine de manifestations
nous descendons à la rencontre des
citoyens et jeu mais je pense que vous
devriez le faire un peu plus souvent et
vous entendrez effectivement ce qu'ils
disent
ensuite je vais vous dire que vous dit
quelque chose de trop la majorité des
français et contre cette loi
vous ne pouvez pas dire ce qu'ils
bouffent bon vous semble et sachez quand
même qu'en démocratie monsieur en
démocratie l'opposition à la parole
alors si vous n'aimez pas la démocratie
et c'est ce que l'on voit et bien tant
pis pour vous
nous on continuera à être démocrate les
français aussi
alors vous savez quoi soit vous changer
de façon de faire un choix
on va râler c'est à répondre rémy
rebeyrotte pardon face à sète
cette intervention du jld à l'arrivée on
vous écoute oui non je dis simplement
que les principes de la république et la
démocratie c'est que effectivement la
majorité reste avec les oppositions et
les oppositions respecte de la majorité
cb ça marche dans les deux sens
moi je voulais simplement dire à
monsieur larry qu'il regarde
effectivement aujourd'hui les enquêtes
d'opinion une grande majorité des
français pour la vaccination
une grande majorité des français
considère qu'il ne faut absolument pas
se résigner à l'idée de confier le pays
et il faut aller massivement vers le mac
sédation vais vous dire une chose sur
moi j'étais présent j'étais très inquiet
parce qu'il ya quinze jours les mères ma
circonscription me disais il ya plus
personne dans nous vaccine hautement la
fréquentation est en chute massive
les gens considèrent qu' on a tourné la
page que c'est hermine etc
et en plus il me disait on est en train
de sacrifier des salles pour des
vaccinodromes qui ne vaccinent plus or
ces salles en appoint pour les
associations pour la démocratie locale
pour nos actions j'allais dire au
bénéfice de la population
pas moi je suis ravi si vous voulez
c'est que depuis l'intervention du
président de la république
ces centres fonctionnent les françaises
font vacciner
et moi je suis est ce que vous voulez
que je vous dise excusez moi mais je
suis ravi que nous retrouvions le schéma
de la vaccination et qu'il y ait cette
volonté de la part de nos concitoyens de
se faire vacciner d'encourager la
vaccination de faire de la pédagogie
tous ensemble autour de la vaccination
pour relever ce défi qui est devant nous
et et comme dans tous les pays tous les
pays
le défi c'est la vaccination pour
essayer de faire face pour l'instant
nous avons la chance
les variants sont tous résident y en au
vaccin
j'espère que ça va durer comme ça et que
nous pourrons petit à petit sortir dans
une d'une situation qui est n'est ni
favorable aux entreprises et aux
salariés ni à qui que ce soit
d'autres pays on va conclure rapidement
avec vous michel larive juste cette
question concernant cette contestation
populaire on a vu que de nombreux
français étaient contre ce pas
sanitaires à usage quotidien
certains vont trop loin par exemple en
faisant cette cette comparaison a à
l'étoile jaune vous pensez pas que c'est
exagéré selon vous mais bien entendu et
on la vit ne participons pas ça par
contre je reviens sur ce qui a été dit
la majorité de freud des français sont
peut-être pour le vaccin mais contre
cette loi c'est deux choses différentes
et je vous le redis
si vous vous êtes très inquiet pour ce
qu'il se passe et la recrudescence des
juristes dans notre pays nous assistons
en responsabilité nous aussi mais je
vais vous dire que par exemple je suis
aussi très inquiet j'arrive d'avignon et
je suis très inquiet qu'il n'y ait plus
personne par exemple dans les théâtres
en ce moment il y avait été âpre et qui
décide de fermer parce qu'ils se disent
à quelque chose s'ils vont être mangés
idem pour des restaurants quand des
gendarmes retient une dame qui veut se
jeter dans dans un fleuve parce qu'elle
dit ne pourra pas avoir de travail
comprenez il est instauré dans notre
pays un climat de tension extrême
monsieur je me le demande en
responsabilité retirer cette loi
refaites autre chose nous vous
accompagnerons dans une autre chose dans
la pédagogie comme sont les allemands
les allemands ne veulent pas faire comme
nous madame merkel a raison
pédagogie et gestes barrières vous avez
deux mois pour mettre des purificateurs
dans des écoles nous société de
roulement en responsabilité nous
pourrions de vous vous accompagner dans
ce sens là mais nous sommes contre les
lois liberticides
parce que nous sommes peut-être les
derniers garants des valeurs de
république est souvent seule mais nous
continuerons nous lutterons contre
l'autoritarisme et la colle
l'obscurantisme qui l'accompagnent
sachez le nous serons toujours là pour
mettre en valeur nos valeurs
républicaines
surtout les protéger merci à tous les
deux d'avoir répondu à nos questions ce
soir d'avoir débattu autour de ce
passage était à rémy bohren je rappelle
que d'être député de la république en
marche de saône-et-loire et michel
larive député de la france insoumise de
la 2e circonscription de l'ariège